Oh
the famed physicist Freeman Dyson wrote
about a very near future where a new
generation of artists will be writing
composing genomes with the fluency Blake
and Byron wrote versus the fluency of
Shakespeare in other words our new
alphabet our new technology our new
canvas is life itself the software of
biology right genetics by mastering the
information processes of biology turns
the substrate of life itself
into the raw material for minds to
engage with talk about a recursive loop
talk about us
folding in and ourselves like mind has
now transcended it's biology enough to
turn around and start to tweet if its
own compositions I mean talk about the
evolutionary process slingshotting and
evolving its own evolvability
biotechnology
makes us as gods right as Stewart Brand
said we are as gods and and should
finally get good at it right we ought to
realize that we are the music makers we
are the dreamers of dreams we cast the
spells we invoke the Psalms like it's up
to us this is our moment
you